[Music]
my name
is john patmore lindsay by profession i
am a medical man
and a fellow of the royal college of
surgeons and a member of the royal
college of physicians london
i am also the author of numerous medical
works the best known perhaps
being how to keep in good health and
live long
i was educated at one of the large
public schools and took my degree at
oxford
i have generally been regarded as a
hard-headed man and skeptical about all
phenomena that were not capable of being
explained by rational and known laws
mysticism occultism spiritualism and the
like
only served to excite my ridicule and i
entertained anything but a flattering
opinion of those people who profess
belief in such things
i was pleased to think it argued a
weakness of mind i have referred to the
few foregoing facts about myself
because i wish to make it clear that i
do not belong to that class of nervous
and excitable people
who fall a prey to their own fancies
conjure up shapes and scenes out of
their imaginings
and then vow and declare that they have
been confronted with stern realities
what i am about to relate is so
marvelous so weird and startling
that i am faint to begin my story in a
half apologetic way
and even now as i dwell upon it all i
wonder why i of all men
should have been subjected to the
unnatural and unearthly influence
but so it is and though in a sense i am
only half convinced
i no longer scoff when somebody reminds
me that there is more in heaven and
earth than is dreamt of in our
philosophy
but to my story and when it is told the
reader can judge for himself how
powerful must have been the effect of
what i witnessed
when it could induce a man of my mental
fiber to commit to paper so astounding a
narrative as the one i now pen
it is about 20 years ago that i took up
a practice in the old-fashioned and
picturesque little town
of brinton on sea at that time there was
no railway into britain
the nearest station being some seven or
eight miles away
the result was the town still retained a
delightful
old-time air while the people were as
primitive and old-fashioned as their
town
nevertheless brenton was far ahead of
its neighbors
and though in a purely agricultural
district was enterprising and
business-like
while its weekly tuesday market brought
an enormous influx of the population of
the district for
miles around and very large sums of
money changed hands
being the chief town of the parish and
boasting of a very curious and ancient
church
and a still more ancient market cross to
say nothing of several delightful old
hostile rays
and a small though excellent museum of
local curiosities
consisting principally of roman remains
and fossils
for which the district was renowned it
attracted not only the antiquary
and the gourmand but artists tourists
and lovers of the picturesque
as well as those in search of quietude
and repose
the nearest village was hai lee about
three miles away
between the two places was a wide sweep
of magnificent rolling down
delightful at all times but especially
so in the summer
many an ancient farmhouse was dotted
about with here and there a windmill
the down on the seaside terminated in a
high headland
from which a splendid lighthouse sent
forth its warning beams over the fierce
north sea
second only in conspicuousness to this
lighthouse
was an old and half ruined windmill
known all over the countryside
as the haunted mill when i first went to
live in britain
this mill early attracted my attention
for it was one of the most picturesque
old places of its kind i had ever seen
and as i had some artistic instincts and
could sketch
with as my two flattering friends said
no mean ability
the haunted mill appealed to me it stood
on rising ground
close to the high road that ran between
britain and high lee
i gathered that there had been some
dispute about the ownership
and as is usually the case the suckers
of the harpies of the law had fastened
upon it so to speak
and drained all its vitality away after
the manner of lawyers generally
the old-fashioned legal luminaries of
the country were a slow-going set
and for over a quarter of a century that
disputed claim had remained unsettled
and during that long period the old mill
had been gradually falling into ruin
the foundations had from some cause sunk
throwing the main building out of the
perpendicular
part of the roof had fallen in and the
fierce gales of a quarter of a century
had battered the sails pretty well to
matchwood
a long flight of wooden steps led up to
the principal door
but these steps had rotted away in
places and the door itself had partly
fallen inwards
needless to say this mill had become the
home of bats and owls
and according to the yokels of something
more fearsome than either
it was a forlorn and mournful looking
place anyway
even in the full blaze of sunshine but
seen in moonlight its appearance was
singularly weird
and well calculated to beget in the
rustic mind a feeling of horror
and to produce a creepy and uncanny
sensation
in anyone susceptible to the influence
of utre appearances
to me it did not appeal in any of those
aspects
i saw in it only subject matter for an
exceedingly effective picture
and yet i am bound to confess that even
when transferred to board or canvas
there was a certain grim suggestiveness
of things uncanny
and i easily understood how the
superstitious and unreasoning rustic
mind
was awed into a belief that this
moldering old mill
was haunted by something more creepy and
harrowing than bats and owls
anyway i heard wonderful tales at which
i laughed
and when i learned that the country
people generally gave the mill a wide
berth
at night blamed them for their stupidity
but it was a fact that worthy and in
other respects intelligent farmers and
market folk
coming or going between britain and
highly after dark
preferred the much longer and dangerous
route by the sea cliffs
even in the wildest weather i have dwelt
thus long on the haunted mill
because it bulks largely in my story as
will presently be seen
and i came in time to regard it with
scarcely less awe than the rustics did
it was during the second year of my
residence in britain that a young man
named charles royce
came home after having been absent at
sea for three years
royce's people occupied gorsh hill farm
about two miles to the south of britain
young charlie a fine handsome but rather
wild youngster
had it appears fallen desperately in
love with hannah trousell
who was a domestic and the employee of
the rector of the parish
but charlie's people did not approve of
his choice
and thinking to cure him packed him up
to see and after an absence of three
years and a month
the young fellow bronzed hearty more
rollicking and handsome than ever
returned to his native village i had
known nothing of charles royce or his
history
up to the day of his return but it
chanced on that very day
i had to pay a professional visit to the
rectory and the rector pressed me to
lunch with him
greatly interested in all his
parishioners and knowing something of
the private history of most of the
families in his district
the reverend gentleman very naturally
fell to talking about young royce
and he told me the story adding hannah
is a good girl and i think it's rather a
pity charlie's people objected to is
courting her
i believe she would have made him a
capital wife
has she given him up entirely i asked
oh yes and is engaged to silas hartrop
whose father owns the fishing smack the
north sea beauty
i've never had a very high opinion of
silas i'm afraid he is a little too fond
of skittles and beer
however hannah seems determined to have
him in spite of anything i can say
so she must take her course but i hope
she will be able to reform him
and that the marriage will be a happy
one i really shouldn't be a bit
surprised however if the girl took up
with her old lover again
for i have reason to know she was much
attached to him and i fancy charlie
if he were so minded could easily
influence her to throw silas overboard
this little story of love and
disappointment naturally interested me
for in a country town the affairs of
one's neighbors are matters of greater
moment than is the case in a big city
so it came to pass that a few weeks
after charlie's return
it was pretty generally known that even
as the rector had suggested it might be
young royce and pretty hannah trouselle
were spooning again
and silas had virtually been told to go
about his business
it was further known that silas had
taken his dismissal so much to heart
that he had been seeking consolation in
the beer pot
of course folk talked a good deal and
most of them sympathized with silas
and blamed hannah very soon it began to
be brooded about that royce's people no
longer opposed any objections to the
wooing
and that in consequence hannah and
charlie were to become husband and wife
at christmas
that was in about seven weeks time a
month of the time had passed
and the askings were up in the parish
church when one
day there went forth a rumor that
charles royce was missing
rumor took a more definite shape a few
hours later when it was positively
stated that two nights previously
charles had left his father's house in
high spirits and the best of health to
visit hannah
and walk with her as she was going into
the town to make some purchases
on his way he called at the two wagoners
a wayside inn
where he had a pint of beer and
purchased an ounce of tobacco
from the time he left the inn all trace
of him was lost
and he was seen no more hannah waited
his coming until long past the appointed
hour
and when he failed to put in an
appearance she became angry
and went off to the town by herself next
day her anger gave place to anxiety when
she learned that he had left his home to
visit her
and had not since returned and anxiety
became alarm
when two and three days slipped by
without bringing any tidings of the
truant
on the night that he left his home the
weather was very tempestuous
and it had been wild and stormy sense it
was therefore suggested that on leaving
the two wagoners
he might have got confused when he
reached the common which he had to cross
to get to the rectory
and as there were several pools and
treacherous hollows on the common
it was thought he had come to grief but
the most diligent search failed to
justify the surmise
such an event as this was well
calculated to cause a sensation
not only in britain and its neighborhood
but throughout the county
indeed for many days it was a common
topic of conversation
and at the britain weekly market the
farmers and the rustics dwelt upon it to
the exclusion of other things
and of course everybody or nearly
everybody had some wonderful theory of
his or her own to account for the
missing man's disappearance
one old lady who every week for 20 years
had trudged in from a village five miles
off
with poultry and eggs for the britain
market declared her belief that young
royce had been spirited away
and she recommended an appeal to a
wondrous wise woman
locally known as cracked maul but whose
reputation for solving mysteries and
discovering lost persons and things was
very great
ultimately royce's people did call in
the services of this ancient fraud
but without any result and despite the
wide publicity in every effort on the
part of the rural and county police
to say nothing of 101 amateur detectives
the mystery remained unsolved charles
royce had apparently disappeared from
off the face of the earth
leaving not a trace behind in the
process of time the nine days wonder
gave place to something else
and accepting by those directly
interested in him charles royce was
forgotten
hannah took the matter very seriously to
heart and for a while lay dangerously
ill
silas hartra who was much affected by
his disappointment with regard to hannah
went to the dogs as the saying is and
drank so heavily that it ended in an
attack of delirium tremens
i was called in to attend him and had
hard work to pull him through
on his recovery his father sent him to
an uncle at yarmouth
who was in the fishing trade and soon
afterwards news came that young hartrip
had been drowned at sea
he was out in the north sea and his
uncle's fishing smack
and though nobody saw him go it was
supposed that he fell
overboard in the night this set the
local tongues wagging again for a time
but even the affairs of britain could
not stand still because the
ne'er-do-well silas heartrope was
drowned
so sympathy was expressed with his
people and then the affair was dismissed
about two years later i received an
urgent message late one afternoon
to hasten with all speed to high lee to
attend to the squire there
who had been taken suddenly and as
reports said
seriously ill i had had rather a heavy
day of it
as there had been a good deal of
sickness about for some time passed
and it had taken me several hours to get
through my list of patients
i had just refreshed myself with a cup
of tea and was about to enjoy a cigar
when the messenger came
telling him to ride back as quickly as
possible and say that i was coming
i busied myself with a few important
matters which had to be attended to
as i might be absent for some hours and
then i ordered my favorite mayor
princess to be saddled i set off from
britain
soon after seven it was a november night
bitterly cold dark as erebus while every
now and then
violent squalls swept the land from
seaward
princess knew the road well so i gave
the mare her head
and she went splendidly until we reached
the ruined mill
when suddenly she wheeled round with
such abruptness
that though i was a good horseman i was
nearly pitched from the saddle
at the same moment i was struck in the
face by something that seemed
cold and clammy i thought at first it
was a bat
but remembered that bats do not fly in
november
an owl but an owl would not have felt
cold and clammy
however i had little time for thought as
my attention had to be given to the
mayor
she seemed disposed to bolt and was
trembling with fear
then to my intense astonishment i
noticed what seemed to be a large
luminous body
lying on the roadway it had the
appearance of a corpse
illuminated in some wonderful and
mysterious manner
had it not been for the fright of my
mare i should have thought i was the
victim of some optical delusion
but princess evidently saw the weird
object and refused to pass it
so impressed was i with the idea that a
real and substantial body was lying on
the road
notwithstanding the strange unearthly
light that i slipped from the saddle
intending to investigate the matter when
suddenly it disappeared
and the cold and clammy something again
struck me in the face
i confess that for the first time in my
life i felt a strange
nervous unaccountable fear i say
unaccountable
because it would have been difficult for
me to have given any explanation of my
fear
why and of what was i afraid now
whatever the phenomenon was
there was the hard stern fact to face
that my horse had seen what i had seen
and was terrified there was something
strangely uncanny about the whole
business
and when a terrific squall bringing with
its sleet and rain
came howling from the sea it seemed to
emphasize the uncanniness
and the ruined mill looming gaunt and
grim in the darkness
caused me to shake with an involuntary
shutter
the next moment i was trying to laugh
myself out of my nervousness
princess and i i mentally argued have
been the victims of some atmospheric
delusion
that was all very well but the something
cold and clammy that struck me in the
face
and which may have struck the mare in
the face also was no atmospheric
delusion
with an alacrity i did not often display
i sprang into the saddle
spoke some encouraging words to the
mayor for she was still trembling
and when she bounded forward and the
haunted mill was behind me
i experienced a positive sense of relief
i found my patient at hi lee in a very
bad way
he was suffering from an attack of
apoplexy and though i used all my skill
on his behalf
he passed away towards midnight his wife
very kindly offered me a bed for the
night
but as i had important matters to attend
to early in the morning
i declined the hospitality though i was
thankful for a glass or two of generous
port wine
and some sandwiches it was half past 12
when i left the house on my return
journey
the incident by the haunted mill had
been put out of my head by the case i
had been called upon to attend
but as i mounted my mare the groom who
had brought her round from the stable
said it'd be a bad night doctor for
riding the kind of night when dead
things come out of their graves
i laughed and replied tom ladd i'm
surprised to hear you talk such rubbish
i thought you had more sense than that
well
i tell you what doctor if i had to ride
to britain tonight i'd go by the cliffs
and chants being drowned rather than
pass yon old mill
these words for the moment unnerved me
and i honestly confess that i resolve to
go by the cliffs
dangerous as the road was in the dark
nevertheless i laughed at tom's fears
and ridiculed him
though when i left the squire's grounds
i turned the mayor's head towards the
cliffs
in a few minutes i was ridiculing myself
john pat moore lindsey i mentally
exclaimed you were a fool
all your life you've been ridiculing
stories of the supernatural
and now at your time of life are you
going to allow yourself to be frightened
by a bogey
shame on you i bucked up grew bold
and thereupon altered my course and got
into the high road again
there had been a slight improvement in
the weather it had ceased to rain
but the wind had settled down into a
steady gale and
screeched and screamed over the moorland
with a demoniacal fury
the darkness however was not so intense
as it was
and a star here and there was visible
through the torn clouds
but it was an eerie sort of night and i
was strangely impressed with a sense of
my loneliness
it was absolutely unusual for me to feel
like this
and i suggested to myself that my nerves
were a little unstrung by overwork
and the anxiety the squire's illness had
caused me
and so i rode on bowing my head to the
storm
while the mare stepped out well and i
anticipated that in little more than
half an hour i should be snug in bed
as we got abreast of the haunted mill
the mare once more
jibbed and all but threw me and again i
was struck in the face by the cold
clammy something
i have generally prided myself on being
a bold man
but my boldness had evaporated now and i
almost think my hair rose on end
as i observed that the illuminated
corpse was lying in the roadway again
but now it appeared to be surrounded by
a lake of blood
it was the most horrible weird
marrow-curdling sight that ever human
eyes looked upon
i tried to urge princess forward but she
was stricken with terror
and wheeling right round was setting off
towards hai lee again
but once more i was struck in the face
by the invisible something and its
coldness and clamminess made me shudder
while there in front of us lay the
corpse in the pool of blood
the mayor reared and plunged but i got
her head round
determining to make a wild gallop for
britain and leave the horrors of the
haunted
mill behind but the corpse was again in
front of us
and i shrank back almost appalled as the
something once more touched my face
i cannot hope to describe what my
feelings were at this supreme moment
i don't believe anything human could
have daunted me but i was confronted by
a supernatural mystery that not only
terrified me but the mare i was writing
whichever way i turned that awful
ghastly object confronted me
and the blow in the face was repeated
again and again
how long i endured the unutterable
horrors of the situation i really don't
know
possibly the time was measured by brief
minutes
it seemed to me hours at last my
presence
of mind returned i dismounted and
reasoned with myself
that whatever the apparition was it had
some import
i soothed the mayor by patting her neck
and talking to her
and i determined then to try and find a
solution of the mystery
but now a more wonderful thing happened
the corpse which was still made visible
by the unearthly light
rose straight up and as it did so the
blood seemed to flow away from it in
great gurgling streams
for i solemnly declare that i distinctly
heard gurgling sounds
the figure glided past me and a sense of
extraordinary coldness made me shiver
slowly and gracefully the shining corpse
glided up the rotting steps of the old
mill
and disappeared through the doorway no
sooner had it gone
then the mill itself seemed to glow with
phosphorescent light
and to become transparent and i beheld a
sight that took my breath away
i am disposed to think that for some
moments my brain became so numbed that
insensibility ensued
for i am conscious of a blank when the
power of thought returned
i was still holding the bridle of the
mare and she was cropping the grass at
her feet
the mill loomed blackly against the
night sky
it had resumed its normal appearance
again the wind shrieked about it
the ragged scud raced through the
heavens and the air was filled with the
sounds of the raging wind
at first i was inclined to doubt the
evidence of my own senses
i tried to reason myself into a belief
that my imagination had played me a
trick
but i didn't succeed although the
mystery was too profound for my
fathoming
so i mounted the mare urged her to her
fastest pace
galloped into britain and entered my
house with a feeling of intense relief
thoroughly exhausted by the prolonged
physical and mental strain i had endured
i speedily sank into a deep through
troubled slumber as soon as i got into
bed
i was unusually late and rising the next
day
i found that i had no appetite for
breakfast
indeed i felt ill and out of sorts and
though i busied myself with my
professional duties
i was haunted by the strange incidents
of the preceding night
never before in the whole course of my
career had i been so impressed
so unnerved and so dispirited
i wanted to believe that i was still as
skeptical as ever
but it was no use what i had seen might
have been unearthly
but i had seen it and it was no use
trying to argue myself out of that fact
the result was in the course of the
afternoon i called on my old friend mr
goodyear
who was chief of the county constabulary
he was a strong-minded man
and like myself a hardened skeptic about
all things that smacked of the
supernatural
goodyear i said i'm out of sorts
and i want you to humor a strange fancy
i have
bring one of your best men and come with
me to the haunted mill
but first let me exact from you a pledge
of honor
that if our journey should result in
nothing you will keep the matter secret
as i am very sensitive to ridicule he
looked at me in amazement
and then as he burst into a hearty laugh
exclaimed
i say my friend you are overworking
yourself it's time you gotta locum
tenens and took a holiday
i told him that i agreed with him
nevertheless i begged him to humor me
and accompany me to the mill
at last he reluctantly consented to do
so and an hour later we drove out of the
town in my dog cart
there were four of us as i took peter my
groom with me
we had provided ourselves with lanterns
but good years man
and peter knew nothing of the object of
our journey
when we got abreast of the mill i drew
up and giving the reins to peter i
alighted
and goodyear did the same taking him on
one side i said
i have had a vision and unless i am the
victim of incipient madness
we shall find a dead body in the mill
the light of the dog cart was shining
full on his face
and i saw the expression of alarm that
my words brought
look here old chap he said in a cheery
kindly way
as he put his arm through mine you are
not going into that mill
but straight home again come now get
into the cart and don't let's have any
more of this nonsense
i felt disposed to yield to him and had
actually placed my foot on the step to
mount
when i staggered back and exclaimed my
god am i going mad
or is this a reality once again i had
been struck in the face by the cold
clammy something
and i saw goodyear suddenly clap his
hand to his face as he cried out
hello what the deuce is that aha
i exclaimed exultantly for i no longer
thought my brain was giving way
you have felt it too well something cold
and nasty like struck me in the face
a bad i expect confound them bats don't
fly at this time of the year
i replied by jove no more they do
i approached him and said in a low tone
goodyear this is a mystery beyond our
solving
i'm resolved to go into that mill he was
a brave man
though for a moment or two he hesitated
but on my insisting he consented to
humor me
and so we lit the lantern and leaving
the groom in charge of the horse and
trap
i goodyear and his man made our way with
difficulty up the rotting steps
which were slimy and sodden with wet
as we entered the mill an extraordinary
scene of desolation and ruin met our
gaze
as we flashed the light of the lantern
about in places the floor had broken
away
leaving yawning chasms of blackness
from the mouldering rafters huge
festoons of cobwebs hung
the accumulated dust and dampness of
years had given them the appearance of
cords
i know how the wind moaned eerily
through the rifts and crannies and
broken windows
if ever there was a place on this earth
where evil spirits might dwell
it was surely that ghoul haunted old
mill
the startling aspect of the place
impressed us all perhaps me more than
the other two
we advanced gingerly for the floor was
so rotten we were afraid it would
crumble beneath our feet
my companions were a little bewildered i
think and were evidently at a loss to
know what we had come there for
but some strange feeling impelled me to
seek for something
though if i had been asked to define
that something for the life of me i
could not have done it
forward i went however taking the lead
and holding the lantern above my head
so that its rays might fall afar but
they revealed nothing
save the rotting floor and slimy walls
a ladder led to the upper story and i
expressed my intention of mounting it
goodyear tried to dissuade me but i was
resolute
and led the way the ladder was so creaky
and fragile
that it was not safe for more than one
to be on it at a time
when i reached the second floor and drew
myself up through the trap
i am absolutely certain i heard a sigh
you may say it was the wind i swear it
was not
the wind was moaning drearily enough but
the sigh was a distinctive note
and unmistakable as i turned the lantern
round so that its light might sweep
every hole and corner of the place
i noticed what seemed to be a sack full
of something lying in a corner
i approached and touched it with my foot
and drew back an alarm
for touch and sound told me it contained
neither corn nor chaff
i waited until my companions had joined
me
then i said to goodyear unless i am
mistaken there is something dreadful in
that sack
he stooped and placed his hand on the
sack and i saw him start back
in another moment he recovered himself
and whipping out his knife cut the
string which fastened up the mouth of
the sack
and revealed a human skull with the hair
and shriveled mummified flesh still
adhering to it
great heavens he exclaimed here is a
human body
we held a hurried conversation and
decided to leave the ghastly thing
undisturbed until tomorrow
so we scuttled down as fast as we could
and went home
i did not return to the mill again
myself my part had been played
investigation made it absolutely certain
that the mouldering remains were those
of poor charlie royce
and it was no less absolutely certain
that he had been foully murdered
for not only was there a bullet hole in
the skull and a bullet inside
but his throat had been cut it was
murder
horrible and damnable the verdict of the
coroner's jury pronounced it murder
but there was no evidence to prove who
had done the deed
circumstances however pointed to
charlie's rival
silas hartrop was it a guilty conscience
that drove him to drink
and did the furies who avenge such deeds
impel him
on that dark and stormy night in the
north sea to end the torture of his
accursed earthly life
who can tell the sea holds its secrets
and not a scrap of legal evidence could
be obtained
but though the law declined the
responsibility of fixing the guilt of
the dark deed on silas
there was a consensus of opinion that he
was the guilty party
it was a mystery but the greatest
mystery of all was that i
the skeptic should have been selected by
some supernatural power
to be the instrument for bringing the
foul crime to light
for myself i attempt no explanation
i have told a true story let those who
can
explain it i admit now that there are
more things in heaven and earth
than are dreamt of in our philosophy
you